نبدا مشاهدينا من تهديد موسكو لتل ابيب اذ
حذرت الخارجيه الروسيه اسرائيل من ارسال
الاسلحه الى كياف ماريا زخرفه قالت ان
بلادها لا تصنف الدول بحسب الجغرافيا وان
كل الدول التي تسلم اسلحه يجب ان تفهم ان
اسلحتها ستعتبر اهدافا مشروعه للقوات
الروسيه تهديدات زخرفه وصلت باريس ايضا
حذرت من تزويد فرنسا بالمقاتلات ووصفت
تصريحات مكروه حول الموضوع بالسخيف مشدده
على ان التصعيد الروسي هو الرد
حول بيان الجانب الاسرائيلي بشان تزويدي
اوكرانيا بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق
مبدا الجغرافيا ما نقول ان جميع الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم
اننا سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
قال انه يدرس ارسال مساعدات عسكريه الى
اوكرانيا
لمزيد من المشاركه ففي مقابله مع شبكه
عن ما اذا كان بامكان اسرائيل تقديم
المساعده لاوكرانيا في مجالات مثل القبه
الحديديه التي تحمي اسرائيل من الهجمات
الجويه كماكد انه يدرس هذا الامر بالفعل
واكد انه انا الولايات المتحده نقلت
مخزونه من ذخيره المدعيه المخصصه لاسرائيل
الى اوكرانيا مقارنه بين هذا الجهد
والعمليات التي تشنها بلاده الدائره